e agora a gente vai fazer mais uma
tatuzinho porque está com pouca né Vamos
fazer uma tatuagemzinha aqui porque
sempre que a gente viaja a gente gosta
de fazer
até o próprio Facebook
vai começar E aí galera que assiste meu
canal Vamos fazer mais tatuagem eu vou
fazer um facão aqui e vou fazer uma
pedra de amolar facão aqui que era como
meus avós amolavam as facas e os facões
no interior do Piauí para eu poder fazer
assim ó depois que eu ganhar
facão vou fazer também outra tatuagem
aqui do Hermes o mensageiro E também
como todo mundo reclama que eu não tenho
tatuagem nas costas eu vou fazer
metade metade vou fazer metade metade um
dragão gigante desse lado eu vou fazer
um tubarão imenso desse lado que eu
quero ver quem é que vai reclamar
cantando tatuagem nas costas tá bom
vamos lá com a gente se você curte esse
canal ainda
deixa o seu gostei aí deixa o seu like
aí
Ah deixa eu mostrar o cabelo do câmera
aqui que tá irado também
vou pegar daqui o cabo pode ser até aqui
mesmo provavelmente
esse aqui mesmo maior e o dragão e o
tubarão eu não vou mostrar agora que eu
vou deixar para vocês terem a surpresa
que tem que ficar né não encostando
fechada
essa aqui é a nossa tatuadora aqui na
Irlanda se você tiver em Dublin quem
quiser fazer o seu sua marquinha a sua
riscada no seu corpo já sabe aqui
encontrar ele manda o papo pessoal
habilidade é com as canetas que risca
mano aqui acabou comigo
[Música]
eu não gosto dos meus meninos andarem
por aí né
senão o pessoal diz que os amendoim
aí eu quero que a gente traz ó e aí
galera como é que tá todo mundo aqui
são os barbeiros da Tropa aqui ó aí ó
que a gente também cuscuz com ovo claro
que nós trouxemos de lá né meu jovem eu
sei mordi lá que nós não gosta de
felicidade a gente gosta de que as
pessoas que vocês são os dois do Ceará
né então tem que trazer trazer para se
sentir em casa né velho
tá ligado né então se você precisar aí é
fazer os seus aparar seus pelos aqui em
Dublin na Irlanda Aníbal está aqui é
isso é só chamar a tropa agora vai
tatuar
no Stories do Instagram aqui que dá 1000
para quem
acertasse o que que eu tava fazendo aqui
nesse braço que é que eu ia fazer isso
bem pertinho aqui faca eu [__]
mas ela foi a primeira a dizer e a
primeira coisa que ela disse foi facão
então
[Música]
sensível essa ai [__] como é que o
cara que a galera consegue fazer teia de
aranha no cotovelo
[Música]
que em qualquer lugar
aqui deu para fazer hoje foi a pedra de
amolar facão que é uma coisa muito do
Nordeste assim que fica no chão mesmo a
galera amola assim ó tá ligado vai
jogando
e fiz o facão aqui né Você tem um pix lá
no Instagram para Quem acertar essa
galera peixeira não sei o quê não valia
só valia Se falasse a palavra certa e aí
ó
mas a maior facão depois acaba com isso
rápido
Ixi ficou cruel né é termina o plano
rápido que eu falei tipo parece que tá
querendo matar o cabo né Essa forma
metafórico entendeu Não deu para fazer
ainda das costas porque a gente tem
treino agora e ia demorar muito e enfim
essas coisas são horas né Vocês sabem né
então tem que deitar na maior Calma tem
que esperar não pode apressar a pessoa
que tá fazendo então espero que se você
quiser ver a próxima tatuagem que eu vou
fazer nas costas eu vou fazer outro
vídeo para mostrar só essas daí tá bom
fechado clica em gostei aí essa é a
nossa vida Estamos por aí onde a gente
vai a gente se risca um pouco a poesia
aí para nós nós
nossas marcas de roupa para um robótica
educativo que a minha parte tecnológica
que vocês não conhece já falei lá do
Piauí eu sou Tony Star que não pode ser
mostrar
seu filho não é engenheiro
esse filho não é advogado tá ligado né
você não querido assim
aí ó gostei Comenta aí embaixo Qualquer
coisa sei lá ah que legal Ah lembrou a
senha do Canal Ah te vejo no ano que vem
vocês são tão previsíveis
tamo junto é nós